PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Do you
have Windows workloads
that need modernization?
Keep watching as
we cover how you
can use Anthos to modernize and
run your Windows applications.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and welcome to Anthos 101.
With Anthos, our goal
is to make it seamless
for you to modernize and
manage your workloads
in the environments
that you prefer,
whether it is on-prem,
Google Cloud, Edge,
or a different cloud.
With about 50% of the
enterprise workloads
running on Windows servers,
it's important to see
how Windows workloads can take
advantage of the modernization
benefits that Anthos offers.
Up until recently,
Kubernetes was
limited to Linux-based
applications,
preventing enterprise
applications running on Windows
servers from taking advantage
of the benefits of agility,
speed of development, and
simplified management.
Last year, 2019, the
open source community
brought Windows servers
container support
in Kubernetes 1.14.
Building on the
OSS functionality,
Anthos has added several
out of the box security,
scalability, integration,
and management capabilities,
through features like private
cluster support, shielded VMs,
and regional clusters and
industry-first full weight auto
scaling available
only in Anthos GKE.
By running Windows Server apps
as containers on Anthos GKE,
you can reduce the licensing
burden and vendor dependencies
along with many of the benefits
that Linux applications
have enjoyed for years.
With the general
availability of Windows
on Anthos on Google Cloud,
you can run your Windows
and Linux-based
workloads side by side
with the master or control plane
and the node pools attached
to it.
You can run the SAC semi-annual
channel version or the LTSC,
the long-term servicing channel
version of the Windows Server
in the Windows node pools.
Kubelet and kube-proxy run
natively on the Windows nodes,
allowing you to run mixed
Windows and Linux container
workloads in the same cluster.
Now, whether you're modernizing
an existing Windows app
or creating a new one, the
first thing that you need to do
is to create a cluster to
deploy your Windows-based app.
To do that in the Anthos
UI, create the cluster,
provide a name
and add node pool.
Create a node and select
Windows semi-annual or long term
service channel as
the image, and create.
Once you have the
cluster created,
you can deploy a new Windows
application in the cluster
or migrate an
existing Windows app.
To migrate an
existing application,
you could use Migrate for
Anthos V2K for Windows.
The solution migrates IAS
web applications, ASP.net,
and Windows Server apps
from VMs to Windows Server
2019 containers on Anthos GKE.
It automatically extracts
application files
and configurations
from Compute Engine VMs
and creates a suggested
migration plan.
This is an auto-generated
plan, but you
can customize it if you need.
It generates artifacts like
a ZIP file with application
contents and settings and a
Docker file with the recipe
to build the deployable image.
The Docker file is then
used to build an image
and then validate
the generated image.
We understand that modernizing
your applications entail
more than just deploying
and managing containers.
This is why we're working
with several partners
to build a strong ecosystem.
We're excited to announce that
these partners have already
worked to integrate their
solutions with Windows
on Anthos GKE.
Migrate for Anthos provides
a fast and simple way
to move existing workloads
to modernized orchestration
and application management
without requiring access
to source code, rewriting, or
re-architecting applications.
We are committed to helping you
in your modernization journey,
regardless of the
type of platform
or workloads you use,
Linux or Windows.
Soon, Windows on Anthos will
be available on premises
and on other clouds.
To learn more, check out the
documentation linked below.
And for more Anthos
content, don't
forget to subscribe and follow
the Anthos 101 playlist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]